this is a production of cornell
university
wonderful thank you so much yandi um
you said everything i was going to say
on the first line
i'm so humbled to debut this project
that's been in the minds of many for a
while
and so this is a collaborative effort i
want to recognize the team
harry michelle kate and i are with ars
uh sigan frederie all right michigan
state and the tim's in berkeley we're
also looking for
new members to the team specifically
the data manager position which i will
talk about
more later so the outline for today's
presentation
i just lay out the premise of the
research
uh talk about some previous work that's
been done
and then layout drives objectives and
approaches
finally closing with that facilitated
discussion
[Music]
so the premise of of this
but also of many things these days is
climate change
we know that extreme weather events are
increasing
in frequency and highly simplified
agricultural
systems are more at risk to suffer from
these extreme weather
events in a a wonderful
case in point of some work that i did
with my dissertation research i
interviewed dairy farmers out in western
new york
i asked them about their crop rotations
whether they've
experienced extreme weather events and
how they recovered from them this one
farmer told me
that his banker once said right here
all the farms in this area are hundreds
of thousands of dollars
behind because of those heavy rains
because they've suffered yield losses so
they were
several inches of rain in one morning
and she was able to point out on the map
the dollars and cents that have been
lost
and so when i think about farming a lot
of it is
that financed and so if you can survive
some extreme weather events um
you know maybe that takes a knock into
your system
as to whether you can survive the
subsequent ones
i think crop diversification is a key
element towards
redesigning our our agricultural system
specifically crop rotations and crop
rotations increase the temporal
and spatial variants of the landscape so
you have
crops happening over time in a rotation
and then if you have different crops
those are being planted at different
times you
get that special diversification
and some of the benefits this brings
about different crops have different
responses to stress and extreme events
having crops and rotations break pest
cycles you're reducing those pathogen
loads you're changing up management so
you won't have the same kind of weed
pressure
and then you're also distributes risk
from
say the economic or social
uh systems where you
can spread out risk and reduce um
you know your risk of market volatility
and finally crop rotations
are biophysically change
that landscape in a way that might be
mitigative so
regenerating soil health that would
improve your chances for the next
extreme
weather event and so now i want to turn
this
over to tim who's going to talk about
some of the work
that he's done um and him
thanks ann and uh thanks so much for
being here everybody it's really an
honor to be presenting today with you um
so i wanted to talk about
one of the threads of the genesis
of this project there are a few
different strands that have come
together
in the current work that we're doing and
this is one of them
and so um as many of us probably are
you know a few years ago i was
interested in
us really quantifying the
extent to which crop rotational
diversity
could mitigate risk from stressful
conditions
and to do that you know we really need
to be looking
at the past at what's happened over a
long term
encompassing a wide variety of
types of stressors um and
located across a wide diversity of soils
and climate conditions and so
um inspired by some some work on this at
a few single areas from amelia den and
others
i saw an opportunity to synthesize data
from a number of long-term
cropping systems experiments located
across um
the the us and canada and so
um started getting in touch with folks
and just floating this idea
and i've got an amazing response uh from
folks at 11 uh long-term experiments
that
uh we're looking at crop rotational
diversity uh you see the names of folks
over here that were associated with
these experiments probably a lot of
familiar names
um and these experiments were all
corn-based cropping systems
that was one of the criteria
and they all examined a range of crop
rotational diversity from
either a monoculture or biculture all
the way up to in some cases for
five crop cash crops with a couple of
cover crops in rotation
they varied across each location
depending on the climate conditions the
particular crop other crops and
rotations could have been different
but they all had these commonalities and
they were spread across a wide
precipitation gradient
from about 400 millimeters annual
precipitation in akron colorado
um all the way to about 1100 millimeters
in
beltsville um and so
oh can you go on and to the next one
great and so what i asked for from
um everybody at each one was was
the corn yields in every rotation and
every year
of the experiment at the plot level and
these experiments
varied in length from over 50 years to
over 20 years but all long-term
experiments i'm in altogether
almost 350 site years of data
about 11 000 observations of corn yields
so a fairly large data set and then of
course i also was interested in kind of
experimental metadata that was relevant
and to the extent possible tried to get
important things like planting and
harvest dates
although as one challenge of doing this
type of synthesis work
is that certain types of data are a lot
uh some types of data
are a lot easier to come by from these
experiments and others are much harder
yields are fairly easy other types of
data can be a lot harder to get
and so this is just a picture of kind of
one of these representative experiments
in akron
looking at a number of different
rotations
over a long-term experiment all phases
present in all years
in in each of these experiments so
go ahead and so
i went into this just um wanting to
assess
uh the impact that more diverse
rotations would have
on specifically corn yields across
varying degrees of stress and
just as a starting point i wasn't
focused
on a particular type of stress drought
stress
or or too much precipitation
but just looking at kind of a generic
metric of stress
and um set out with just some very
overly simplified hypotheses
um uh admittedly uh uh
just to kind of get a sense of this so
for instance of course
as um stress is increasing on the x-axis
here we expect yields to go down
and the question was to what extent
did coin yields and the diverse
rotations differ in their response to
trap
stress relative to corn yields in
simplified rotations
we could imagine lots of different
scenarios here one
being for instance that actually at low
levels of stress
that's where we see the benefits of
rotation but then those decline as
stress increases
or we could have another type of
response where
when in productive growing conditions
yields are similar especially if there's
sufficient inputs
but then we see the benefits of rotation
appear
when stress increases and so
i set out to test this with a few
different methods i'm just going to show
you
one of those here and you can go on to
the next slide in
so we um used uh some
bayesian multi-level models to test this
as well as uh the
result that i'm showing here which is a
probability analysis uh something that
we
borrowed from the way that
uh insurance actually assesses risks
um looking at uh the probability
uh of crop failure um that is yields
less than the 10 percentile or the
increased opportunity for for so-called
bumper crop crops or crop yields greater
than the 90th percentile
and then comparing those um
probabilities
between uh in this graph we're just
showing that the most simplified
rotation at each site and the most
complex rotation at each site
and so in with the simple rotation we
have this in purple and the complex
rotation we have this in green
and the sites are arranged from lowest
to highest mean annual precipitation
and so you without going into a
tremendous amount of detail here
basically if the green bars are shifted
to the right
relative to the purple bars that means
that we have an
increased likelihood of bumper crops and
a decreased likelihood of crop failure
in the diversified rotations
and that's what we found at about uh
nine
out of the 11 sites we see
at the dry site in akron as a different
story where actually the simple
rotations
outperform the more complex rotations
and i think this is largely a water
story
but some really compelling kind of first
look at this
idea that rotational diversity can
actually not only get mitigate risk but
also increase opportunity
when productive during productive
growing conditions
so if you want to go on to the next
slide in so
in our first look at this we didn't hone
in on a particular type of stress
um but uh you know i got my phd in
california during
the 2011 to 2015 drought and that has
just made a huge impression on me
in terms of the challenges that we face
going forward here even in the irrigated
systems we have out here
much less rain fed systems that
constitute most of the corn growing
regions
so i wanted to hone in on drought as a
particular type of
important stress and so we looked at
in each county of the u.s sites we had
two canadian sites but we looked at the
crop
insurance the indemnity payments and
this the cause of payment
and each of the counties where these
experiments were located over a 20-year
period
and found that in most cases drought was
the most common reason for crop
insurance payouts in the counties
where these sites in the u.s were
located
and so then the next step was to look at
the three years
in each of the sites that had the
largest
payouts for drought in these counties
as a proxy for actual drought impacts
in these areas and then compared it
yields in the simplified versus diverse
rotations and you can go on the next
slide in
and so this is just looking now at the
percent difference
in simple versus complex rotations
during these three putative drought
years
and what we see is that in six of the
nine u.s
sites we see significantly higher corn
yields
in the complex rotations versus the
simplified rotations during these
putative drought
years and so we
have a lot more work to do to understand
the mechanisms behind this
but this is uh one of the uh really
i think motivations behind the work that
we're doing now
if you want to go on in
and so just some high level conclusions
from this
so greater crop rotational diversity
increased
reduced the impacts of stressful
conditions on corn yields
but it also increased yields during more
productive growing seasons
one thing that i didn't show here was
that we looked at some of these
experiments
also were in a factorial design with
nitrogen inputs and so we could assess
the extent to which
uh just nitrogen was behind this crop
rotational diversity effect
and when we looked at that we found that
when nitrogen inputs were high the
benefits of crop rotation were somewhat
reduced but certainly not eliminated
so nitrogen availability i don't think
can entirely substitute at all
for the positive effects of rotational
diversity that we were seeing and
um and if you want to go on to the next
one
and the there's so there's been
i think a lot of interest in in looking
at long-term agricultural experiments in
this sort of synthesis way
both from the standpoint of kind of
yield resistance resilience stability
um a couple of recent papers on this the
sanford aisle looked at one site in
wisconsin
one of the sites that was included in
our synthesis as well
this mourinho came out last year and was
looking at
about seven sites in europe uh found
very similar conclusions to what we
found
and others have looked at a broader
suite of ecosystem services as well
and so that brings us to our efforts
here
to create a network of
long-term data from these experiments
and so i'm going to hand it back over to
ann now to tell you more about where
we're heading
thanks tim um so this worked to
initiate a network of long-term data
as tim mentioned that it has been in
thinking about it for a while but it
really kicked off in this corn and
context workshop
in ames 2018 hosted by
matt liebman and marshall mcdaniel and
the goal was to start to integrate a lot
of data that had been collected
from multiple research experiments and
start
thinking about things more at a cropping
systems
level in order to understand the impacts
of diversity
to agronomic performance and
particularly
in the face of climate change to yield
stability
and so as legend has it
from this conference there were a group
of scholars
that all took a shuttle together back to
the airport
and in this ride they decided they were
going to write a grant
and this is the grant that funds my
postdoc
today so the drives project
uh works to network these long-term
cropping systems
projects and it also funded two data
manager
positions and the link is here on the
website and i'm
on the website the link for the job is
here
on their presentation so i encourage
anybody
if they might know anybody to send this
presentation along it is being recorded
so it will be available
the drive's objectives we have three
main objectives and the first one of
course is to build
the database and so we'll get into some
details
about that um there were
13 long-term sites that signed on as
collaborators
and committed to sharing their data
in the grant proposal and as jim
mentioned you know they range across
soil and weather variability
the criteria for being included in the
drives network
that it needs to be the sign needs to be
in north america
have at least three full rotations
of data and be a corn based rotation so
corn and monoculture
or two or more uh crops in rotation
so if this is you or you might know
anyone
who fits this criteria um
please pass this information along and
reach out because we're interested
in adding more sites
and here's some some detail about this
site
a lot of the the ltar sites are
here there's also the lter
kbs in michigan they span several
decades
and then just going into detail about
one of the sites
as an example the farming systems
project
located in maryland was
established in the mid 90s and it has
two conventional systems corn soybean
wheat rotation and three organic
systems with different rotations
ranging in the amount of cover crops and
one has a perennial
forage component and so across a lot of
the sites
there is agronomic performance being
measured
there is soil data that has been
collected
and of course each of their sites have
like the
the pet measurement that they like um
and so
this site has greenhouse gas emissions
and also assesses economic performance
and so this is just an example of of one
of the sites
that will be included the database
we want to gather ecosystem services
data
from these long-term sites so this
includes provisioning services
like crop yields or cover crop yields
supporting services such as the
soil measurements measurements of
biodiversity and then
regulating services so greenhouse gas
emissions
um indicator insect species for breaking
those
pest cycles as we spoke about and then
water quality so nitrate or erosion
rates
and so this this is like this part of
the graph and then
the more difficult aspect is collecting
management data so
specific planting and harvesting dates a
lot of metadata attached with that
and pairing it with with weather data
and so we've come up with three steps
essentially of how we envision this data
collection
process to go and you will see in the
slide how crucial
the data manager position is
and so in the first phase we want to
capture the low-hanging fruits so we'll
have
early simplified data management
protocols
uh work on collecting crop yields
um that should be pretty standard
for each of the sites and so you know
building out
from not just corn but the other crop
yields in rotation
cover crop biomass in the second phase
we'll get
uh we'll mature the data protocols
and start automating the data
acquisition
and aggregation and so the drives data
manager will work with a lot of scale
related issues
for example with soils maybe one site
has measured at the plot level
another site has measured at the field
level for soils or
they've taken them at different depths
and then
finally um for our taxpayers the
automation of data analysis
and visualization so we would like
um to develop a user-friendly interface
that you can use to explore the database
on your own understanding the kind of
relationships between
variables that you're interested in
and so rubber meets the road here's how
we're thinking about this
we have um tim's amazing data set that
he's
started that he's put together and then
we want to build
off of that initial structure stand on
the
shoulders of giants and then reach out
to the individual
sites as to collecting more data and
develop this database on ad cross
what is a cross you might say
well this is the ag um
it's a diverse network of databases that
facilitate the flow
of information and increase cooperation
among researchers participating in these
networks
so really like the next you know next
generation of data
management where we're starting to
really integrate
a lot of data sets together and so
each of these spokes represents one
of the networks that's hosted on
ad cross and they each have their own
particular agenda
and drives will have a spoke added
as well and we would be looking at
things that are cropping
system levels so looking at ag data at a
cropping system
level so that's the database
and the second objective has two parts
the first part is assessing effect
of yield on rotational assessing the
effect of the
rotational complexity on yield yield
stability and response to stress and
extreme
weather events so we've we've talked
about this already
and this is something heretical to a
group of
scientists but we're at my my kitchen
table
more data alone
will not get us to more complex crop
rotations and so it's important
in this early phase as we're building
out this database to start thinking
how can science be tractable with
the current system that exists and
what are specific policies or
or vehicles that we would like to look
at
for instigating some change
so the objective the second objective
here is using
findings from uh qa
and applying it to crop insurance risk
assessments and we're
we're early days on this one and
to give a background like a really
broad background on federal crop
insurance
after nutrition crop insurance
accounts uh is the second largest title
in the farm bill it's about 40 billion
dollars about 10
of farm bill funding goes to crop
insurance
and it's a taxpayer it's taxpayer funded
and it's a public private system so
it's overseen and subsidized by the
government
but it's carried out by private
insurance companies so it's overseen by
an agency the risk management
agency that looks over this pool of
money
called the federal crop insurance
corporation
and then and then these
the rma subsidizes federal crop
insurance
that is carried out by private companies
and
the large majority of these insurance
payouts go to
high production agriculture so a lot of
smaller a lot of larger
farms here
and so we're proposing that
the current u.s crop insurance as a
lock-in mechanism
for simplified rotation crop insurance
is a
general premise is intended to reduce
producer risk
but the way that it's structured on a
single
crop often creates these perverse
incentives
that reward a lot of simplified
uh cropping rotations and penalize
more innovative production practices
and as an example and jim references uh
you know this drought during 2012
this was a big moment for me to to
understand you know like the ago
landscape
and so this is an example of crop
insurance payouts
uh during that drought period
we can see these dark rectangles here
that's over
10 million dollars of payouts in each
county
here and it you know it it um
it really makes me
consider like what is the question how
do we account for risk
in crop insurance so right now this is
very broad very early days
calculated much like car insurance here
it's based on a single season
and it does not account for rotational
effect and if you aren't counting
something
then it does not count
and so what we'd like to do with the
data set
that we're developing early on is start
to look at
how can we calculate risk more like life
insurance and life annuities so basing
it off of the
cropping system which does account for
the rotational
effects
and then finally the drives
objective the third objective um
which really is quite an exciting one
is to look at the biophysical mechanisms
that are driving the rotational effects
of course we can't quite do this until
we get the data set
up and running but this is where the key
questions are of like
how do you design a you know like a
cropping system that is more resilient
to drought or that you know it doesn't
improve water reporting capacity where
are these key
key points by looking at the biophysical
mechanisms and so um
i'm going to close out here and
[Music]
uh thank you all and take any questions
clarifying crop uh clarifying the
presentation so far before handing it
over
to stick
questions yeah dominique go ahead
friend hi sorry yeah um
i was just wondering whether you've
looked at all of the implications of
scaling up these diversity
rotations generally that would
presumably change a lot the
nature of the food that's created over
all the food system and there would have
to be dietary changes associated with
that as well
is that a major barrier or would there
be health benefits from these
the changing types associated or is it
or is it a show stopper that means that
we can't really do it how does that play
out
wow that's a that's a big
question tom um
so are these would diversif
if i understand it correctly would
diversifying crop rotations then
instigate
changes in diet and lifestyle and
you know like very very big larger
societal
questions um
just to claire if i meant to in the
sense that you would then be growing a
lot more of other crops and less corn
for example the actual food produced
in the country as a whole would be a
very different mix to what we have now
so ann if i can come in i just wrote a
paper on this published in frontiers
uh that in indeed this has been raised
as the green revolution the rationale is
we need to feed
you know 10 million people
and so does this produce enough calories
as one of the main questions but in fact
nutrition might be improved there's some
nice work out of india
looking at minor crops and legumes
pulses coming in replacing
corn which has been going up very fast
in india and then of course wheat and
rice can you still feed people
of course this gets into bigger
questions than than we are initially
looking at the farming systems level
there's some other initiatives ltr and
others are thinking about
the whole landscape level which is more
which you're getting at but i think
these are very important questions
because
the market demand for the crops and the
nutritional implications
we need to explore these along with
these types of questions here in order
to then inform policy
because mostly it's been said well this
just won't produce enough calories so
this is why we have to focus on corn and
corn soybean but that's debatable
because
that implies you know the commodity
chains are basically
set up around using corn soybean
products and they could use other
products
and also uh
you know you lose a lot of efficiency as
soon as you go into livestock
and so there's it's it's a very big
picture and thanks for bringing that up
starting us off in that way is there any
clarifying questions for ann
we'll come back to you good point
dominique
um jeff has his hand up
yeah maybe it's not clarifying it was
going to respond to the
the answer um in one way
commodity crops aren't largely eaten
that's
the simplest answer but the other thing
is that what we're seeing in montana is
particularly organic systems we are
i mean this is over 20 years of my life
almost 30 years of my life here in
montana
watching us integrate for instance
pulses
into the rotations with wheat which is a
an amazing phenomena but it took
30 years and uh and
yes and that and those are more crops
that we can eat chickpeas and
wonderful lentils and all of those
things so
it can happen with those crops that you
can eat but
as far as the midwest i don't see that
same and we have ancient grains and
many of those things and i don't see
those happening in other regions of the
country
well at least particularly in the
midwest
right so i think we're getting off a
little bit i would like to get back to
that at some point
because i think it's really important
because it's often said why we can't
diversify is because of this
calorie production uh and there's
starting to be some literature
in this area which tim and i just shared
in the chat uh but let's just go ahead
and see what questions that you're
thinking about
at the field and farming system level
because
i think i can say that we if i can
stretch this analogy
that we want to drive this in the right
direction
and we need your help to drive it so
we are still looking for collaborators
at different levels we're looking for
further long-term trials so
can we just go over a little bit some of
the discussion questions and then we'll
come back to the big picture which you
guys are so good at
uh so is there please put in the chat
and i can
kind of summarize that or just pipe up
uh are there some research questions
that excite you about this data set
and we've listed some of our draft
hypotheses right there
uh for your reference
we've seen some some of the work that
tim bulls and colleagues have started
buffering of uh stress
but i think there's both in resilience
theory we know there's both pushes
stresses but there's also extreme
you know 100 year floods uh when
the extreme droughts in california so
buffering
for extreme events there's still very
little literature on that might take
some modeling
but might be explored here what about
other
breaking pest cycles reducing economic
risk someone
raised the issue of are we going to look
at economics
i'm regenerating soil health there's so
many questions on
sega that just uh this is andy i just
wonder what your plan is to try to
decompose these stressors
uh i mean i i assume that it's very
important to understand
sort of the mechanisms at play and so do
you have long-term weather data
at these sites and tim you mentioned
earlier you had some
information on planting dates that could
give you some idea on phonology
but what's your plan for sort of parsing
the story in terms of understanding
um the functional benefits of of
these diverse rotations vis-a-vis the
threats that you're listening listing
here
well thanks for for raising that andy so
what time horizons are spatial scales
are you particularly we're really
curious what
people are thinking yes we're going to
use weather data and some different
statistical including bayesian
approaches
and we also want to explore using app
sims and modeling approaches
but we'd like to hear like what time
horizons spatial skills do you think
would be particularly interesting for
these questions
well i mean i think that the just
starting with the the very provocative
data that tim put up
showing that in some years these where
you've defined a stress condition but
that seems like a basket of
a reflection of a basket of of stressors
based on a
deviation from a long-term trend right
what's going on
right of course you know then it then it
it opens up the
the discussion to consider the species
in rotation
so thinking about whether or not this is
really a reflection of of soil
regeneration
and changes to the hydrologic cycle and
the buffering that that creates or if
this is really around
pests and diseases i mean i guess this
is a big challenge of working with
historical data we really don't know
but you might be able to define the
residual if you look more carefully at
weather events
i mean i think you're just starting with
the with the sites themselves
is the is the is the really great place
to start because you've already put so
much into this
yeah i think i think that's right i mean
i think um
you know building in the weather data is
going to be critical and
um i think one advantage of taking this
not
um this cross side approach too is that
we'll we have
uh we'll have a lot of variability um
in both soil properties hopefully
changes in soil properties across
rotations
information on pest and disease pressure
potentially
and if we have variation and we have a
lot of data points you know
we might be able to start sorting out
some of these mechanisms at least
um at least in a uh
pointing us in the right direction if
not testing them explicitly
and you know there have been i think you
know i think coupled with this
um and there's a couple of these uh this
work in progress with others is things
like
uh imposing rain out shelters on these
experiments and testing things directly
and um i know there's some work on that
i believe going on at kbs
and um emily gooden i think is on this
call and has had
some work in alora ontario doing this so
i think that we're going to see some
interesting
um results coming out soon that do
provide a little bit more
information on mechanisms that are quite
complementary to this
historical synthesis that we're doing
thanks tim um lewis longchamps want to
come in
yes so i was wondering uh
i mean did the the some of the
i mean the work here some of the
objectives are to improve
soil health uh water quality
and uh like indicated we reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
and uh so improve the the environmental
uh health indicators and you mentioned
the biodiversity
so we know that biodiversity is one of
the
when we look at the planetary boundaries
i mean this is the one that is the most
off of uh the chart and away from the
safe space for for humanity uh
so what have has been done so far to
measure
biodiversity and uh are there new
metrics that you are thinking about
for uh to to quantify or to qualify the
biodiversity
at those locations so that's a really
good question and there are
some some of the sites have taken
indicator species approaches
and some have more detailed soil biology
type diversity questions so some have
used like ladybug beetles
as indicator species or specific
pollinators and others
are looking at decomposition which may
be related to biodiversity
in the soil so the regenerating soil
health we want to decompose because a
lot of a number of
projects have looked at corn yield in
particular but now we're interested in
things like
um you know some of these other not just
breaking pest
cycles but as you said pollination or
soil carbon accrual
and then so both how what are drivers of
these
and then also how they impact then
economics for example
and and other ecosystem services so it's
quite open
and thanks for reminding us we should
really should have greenhouse gases not
all the sites have that but some do
and think more about the biodiversity in
particular
which some interesting diversification
meta-analysis have shown us that
especially pollinators
or something that we may want to think
about i'm really interested in what's
enough diversity to support those i
think we've proven
that you can support pollinators through
crop diversity but
is enough for you know do we have to
have a lot of diversity or even just two
crops has been shown for
aphid um predators for example just
having soybeans in the rotation can
really alter markedly
versus continuous corn so is that how
much services do we get from that so
that might be one direction we could go
other thought questions this is your
time
um yeah we would definitely want to look
at this
as peter's put in the chat monoculture
and then corn soybean and then more
complex
rotations because corn soybean is after
all what many
farmers do rely upon so um what sort of
sets of services can they get from that
or
having a small grain or another diverse
crop in the rotation how much
extra benefits we get from that or
perenniality as was raised earlier by
andy
um so the more landscape level diversity
like prairie strips
is only at a few sites like iowa and now
michigan state's putting some of those
in
so we will have to focus on mostly
diversity
in terms of uh temporal although we may
be able to get some at cover crop
diversity for some spatial
integration let's respond to
andy's question in the chat here about
using satellite monitoring
um yeah this is something that um we've
also been
not as part of this project but as a
related work um
we're we've been using uh cropland data
layer
to in my lab to map crop rotational
diversity across
nine states and so hope to be getting
that out
soon at the field scale um
and then the tricky part is the yields
and
getting field scale yield data and rma
is no longer available through
rma um yeah and so the alternative
is various types of remote sensing or
remote sensing coupled with modeling and
there's a couple of good data sets out
there
that we're looking at to to make those
connections
um at that regional scale using remote
sensing data
um so yeah that's a great great point
andy that that's something that is
kind of being pursued in tandem here
and this point raised by michael snow
too about
energy efficiency often we use economics
as a way to compare apples and oranges
as you have with
multiple crops but energy efficiencies
i've done work at ltr
uh at kbs with this with gelfand and uh
robertson
and this is where it really is startling
whether
you're you're talking about conversion
of energy a system that's really for
um energy production
like fuel wood or if it's for through
alfalfa and and then converted for
animal use or corn converted for animal
really the ultimate use really alters
that markedly but still that's calories
is another approach
yeah water balances thanks ray for that
that's a good point maybe we should
switch to looking at crop insurance as
there
seems to be interested interest in that
in the chat
and you have any specific questions
about how crop insurance might be
reimagined as more ecological insurance
you're thinking the first step would be
this more
whole rotation system jeff did you have
a question
yeah well i was going to comment on that
um i spent about 18 years working on a
a very specific policy called whole farm
revenue protection which i
talked on recently and folks that's why
i got invited here but
yeah and and uh appreciate that nice
slide
on the peak drought uh and some of the
other things but um
it it it is a policy setup that
specifically is available in every
county and specifically
uh incentivizes diverse diversity and
cropping and
livestock systems it's the only policy
that does so
the other thing i would mention which
i'm which is actually
in operation now is what they call index
or parametric insurance
which is um they use it for past
forage protection now essentially it is
working off of data and essentially in a
grid on the earth
and if your grid shows through the data
that you
had a forage loss you get paid so it's
actually it's a kind of an interesting
way to
change change the whole system of
crop insurance from the way it is and
i'll just finally add that
the way it is right now is making it
very difficult
everything you've been proposing here it
would
would jeopardize everyone's crop
insurance currently
and that would be a huge barrier to
production of anything that you come up
with this
unless you can reform that
is are really good points this is why i
think we need really good data to inform
evidence um maybe christina can can you
share that with everyone your point
because you sent us a direct message to
me
about diversification at the landscape
level
christina do you want to share
okay you're pointing out the
distribution of diversified systems
drives the creation of multi
um how does it drive the creation of
multifunctional landscapes so
can we think about specific services i
think we are
all these comments here are challenging
us to think about implications for
you know main street implications for
whole watershed
uh we are because of how these field
crop experimentation long-term
experiments have been set up they are at
the field and farm level
so even getting from field to farm and
not just thinking corn but the whole
rotation
is actually an important first step
but i think we really take on board
these points that we need to then think
bigger picture on this um and
so is enough diversity for which
services needs to be asked about the
farm
and the watershed level very good point
christina
anyone else want to come in
i i think
tim you and i have mentioned like just
briefly
talking about like how can we use
like would you be able to model
diversification
using the the cropland database
for more complex rotations and then from
that
modeling like would you be able to say
something
at a landscape level i think that's a
really interesting
question
or premise both
yeah i think i think that is um i think
that scaling
that extrapolation question is is really
important um
and i would uh i do think it would be
interesting for us to consider
some simulations like that um
and think of work from megan chapinski
and steve rosenzweig kind of doing this
and
um intensified wheat rotations kind of
scaling up from
field level data to uh to the great
plains
um and uh you know in terms of
implications for
for certain ecosystem services so um
yeah i think i think that's i mean to me
in terms of
i think our ultimate aims here which you
know i think is
i hope to get the attention of you know
maybe naively get the attention of
policy makers at the various levels but
i do think
you know as if we can scale up um you
know at least with
in and be very um uh um
open and honest about our uncertainty
with that scaling then then that
is uh maybe a more
um powerful scale to get people's
attention on
yeah certainly the first step will be
building
you know like uh building it out at the
field level
based on the data that we have and then
and then generating estimates at the
landscape
level holding all else the same because
you know you change one aspect of the
system then some other
thing changes as as andy just referenced
like
changing price or because you probably
have some like spatial adoption
happening where if it's more adopted in
one region
right but if you were to just hold
everything else constant to generate
some estimates that you know
might seem very tantalizing
at a policy level i think that seems
promising to catch a tension
yeah and i think uh that
will definitely build on i mean there's
been a lot of work done on organic too
organic and diversified agriculture
tends to occur in areas in the landscape
that are
lower value and that are more uh diverse
than
the really high value tends to be more
intensified
so i think um that
as you just said and we're gonna build
on these and in
uh to your point andy about um
profitability yes
individual sites have of course done
profitability analyses
just like the energy prof you know
economics is an important way
to consider across systems
but we're going to try and rebuild that
out again
so through this cross-site type of
approach
and so depending on the type of risks uh
that we're considering we may use
subsets of of the
experiments and we again want to
encourage
you to share with us uh the
other sites that you know about that
might fit in this analysis
that we can use for testing you know for
further questions
so there's something some points in uh
so what advantages come from scale
diversification within field versus
between fields
in a defined region from kiera
that's a really good question again this
is very much
the experiments have focused on field
diversification so
either rotational diversification or
cover crops within a field
so that's what we can initially test
so we can look to some extent
at using some of these other types of
models there's a number of economic
models that i can think of that we can
go to
to ask these bigger questions about what
happens when you know when you have to
take into account price in that case
i think uh between to try and understand
how that might play out but then that's
why we're one of our first
products or projects is going to
particularly look at crop insurance
because that so much
informs farmers decision making
and in turn policy impacts on
environment i think
um so so jeff you're pointing out you
have some diverse and complex organic
larger scale system examples in montana
yeah the famous lentil example indeed
i think is something we could take a
look at
even more than lentils it's there's
people that have eight year rotations
with
um sometimes 20 different crops
i mean these are existing farms that
i've watched for many years
right and i think that reason it's well
with the california context
so we have 400 crops we're in an
irrigated landscape and the site that is
you know our site at restaurants is a
little bit of
odd in in that list uh in many ways
so i was wondering um is that are there
other sites where
maize is irrigated um and how would we
deal with that how well the models can
handle this kind of
inputs and how how we're thinking around
um buffering extreme you know the
capacity of
of biodiversity to buffer extreme
weather events in those
in those irrigated systems
yeah some of the north dakota sites uh
or at least somewhere in the great
plains they do have some irrigated corn
experiments there so that's a good point
that we have to think about some systems
are closer to the yield potential
than others because water is taken care
of so i certainly would think that
those wouldn't be as good as an example
to include uh
for testing drought obviously i think
it's it's a matter of
again we're trying to take a lot of time
at the beginning here to we're taking
this over time right to think about the
questions
because there are many different ways we
can do some data mining and see what is
there but we
we also really want to be very uh you
know
think very thoughtfully about which
types of questions might be of most
interest that haven't been thought about
because
in fact there has been there's quite a
lot being done in this space right now
which is exciting
and to build off of what sages said
um our team has spoken quite a bit about
the timing aspect so it's like is the
drought
happening at planting time and
i'm not sure about you know california
you know forage production the the
russell ranch
but in terms of the northeast you know
like you know
there are these key times where if you
have an extreme event
it can really sink a system
and so part of that is getting the meta
metadata like when were these planting
dates when were these harvesting dates
so we can hypothesize
about you know narrowing this time range
down to look at particular
events in particular times where you
might say
turn on the irrigation and then you know
perhaps you would not have this drastic
of an impact
on crop production during the drought if
you
get the crop established but the
the crux of it i would say just coming
into this is like
planting dates are very easy to say but
very
might be like much harder to collect in
terms of
generating like this database and
connecting the evidence to the actual
management that's happened on those
experiments
yeah i think we'll do we'll do some deep
dives on on timing and
i also want to point out that that we
have a scale-up
experiment that just completed at kbs
which we published in pans and we found
that in fact the organic more
complicated experiment one of the
challenges
is that it's all about timing and so
what you can do on a plot level
which you might be able to achieve in
some of these long-term experiments you
can't necessarily
do at a farm level so that's one of the
challenging things about
farmers taking on more diversified
cropping is not just equipment
but it's the knowledge and it's the
timing to be have time
to to do it at exactly the right time uh
is is you know it's not trivial so these
are some of the whole farm
level aspects that are will be more
challenging to get at
but we appreciate this this feedback is
there any other
like sort of deep dive type questions
around
regenerating soil health for example
that people want to talk about
because i think this is these sets are
actually better for that type of
question
like does perenniality or just diversity
is it enough to regenerate soil health
for which functions
so how are you are you going to go back
into these long-term trials and do some
direct assessments and if so what are
you going to measure
no this is this is data i think
maybe we weren't quite clear enough that
we are using the historical data
uh that we're building out this huge
database that's that's what this
is basically um to to now be able to
you do post-talk um analyses to try and
understand
some of the findings and then try and
extrapolate at the whole farming system
level rather than
just a corn response which of course
doesn't take into account that in a
diverse experiment
uh diverse treatments you have less corn
which may be the most productive right
so it's really just the next incremental
step although we hope that it'll raise
all these other questions like
implications for insurance for example
does that
make answer your question yeah i guess
from a research methodological uh
perspective i'm
just curious how you're going to put the
soul health lens
into interpretation of the long-term
trends and if there's anything that
could be done
um just snapshot in time i mean all
these experiments still exist
to understand sort of how soil health or
physical properties in particular have
changed with time
well fortunately there is pretty good
data on the soil health
aspect and there's even been some recent
the soil health initiative and others
have even
been building out this with some of
these same trials so
i think that we'll i mean just looking
at soul carbon what
are drivers of that will be i think
helpful uh
as a first step which of course relates
to many other
functions once you have sol uh carbon
accrual
but it does often take um as a recent
paper from ltr
showed it may take you know 15 years
before you see
are really able to detect changes in
soul carbon with different treatments
but we do
have deep data sets so
yeah and i think that that question is
really really spot on
um in terms of like how do you do that
with when you're just looking at
historical data
and i think we could have some creative
approaches here in terms of
um you know developing like some indices
of uh yield stability or yield
resistance to stress
and then um you know predicting that
with the
change in soil a given soil property
between
uh two rotations um or something you
know i'm
i think that that if what
what is again a real um
boon for this is that we have a lot of
observations
um and a lot of uh and so
um you know building a more complex
model that incorporates a lot of
interactions um
you know some structural equation model
or you know some something in that realm
that um can get at the the
interdependencies here i think is gonna
is is likely gonna be a way we'll have
to go um
but then it's still just clues right i
mean these this is still
it's still correlative um but but i
think
our you know one thing that i keep
coming back to is you know the mechanism
is important for us
as biophysical scientists as
people who want to know what's going on
the ultimate
outcome in terms of a risk reduction
doesn't matter what the mechanism is in
a lot of ways
if we can quantify that and
uh unless you know unless we're talking
about using it in
the mechanism in a predictive model um
which
which in the in which case that that
would be important but um
uh yeah so i think uh yeah i think
trying to keep that in mind or that's
something i try to keep in mind too is
when do we need to know and when
is it maybe uh not as important to to be
able to pin it down
well i think we are up on the top of the
hour and that's a really great
ending tim so we really want to thank
everyone and we do have to have one
shout out for bays we are using bayes
regressions as well as structural
equation modeling so
these are some of the collaborators that
were at the first famous
matt and marshall corning context
and we appreciate all of them who will
be coming
knocking on their doors for data and we
appreciate all of you showing up
today thanks so much and uh please feel
free to join us in this
driving endeavor together to try and
understand
so thanks for this wonderful discussion
this opportunity really good questions
you all
asked us to start thinking big picture
from the beginning i think we'll circle
around on that
thanks everyone thank you thank you tim
and sig that was really wonderful
we deeply appreciate you coming in today
thank you so much
thanks so much for having us there's a
lot of fun
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu